like I feel like you know you know what
we're saying and you know that we're
right but you just kind of like to argue
a little bit no radio I think I I I have
a lot of I've been around people that
have explained how they felt and don't
get me wrong like I I don't really I
wouldn't really like my child to say oh
I'm a transgender and I I was really
pissed off when Caitlyn Jenner won a
woman of the year because that really
pissed me off because I've been a woman
for you do you know what I mean like
they're women doing amazing things and
you're going to give it to a man that's
just not that much
he was a man and then when he
transformed into a woman then why are
you mad
it's a woman he hasn't even been a woman
for that long and he hasn't even done
anything
I thought you said in the beginning that
it's anyone that feels like a woman no
no but I'm saying the fact that you won
the woman yeah that's my problem with
that right but I'm saying why would you
have a problem because they're other
women I've done a lot of things and for
a long time
she's done stuff you know I mean Caitlyn
Caitlyn Jenner broke records I'm sure if
it was the women's division I've got to
identified as a man yeah don't come in
our turf until you've done the footwork
then you can be like oh I've done this
as a woman and then you can win the
woman of the year I mean I think he's
done the work you see him recently he's
got some surgery no you guys no I think
it's just I just don't like people
telling people what they can be and what
they can't be as long as you're not
hurting anyone
you can do what you want with you you
can do what you want with you
can actually win it you can you can do
what you want with your body but the
problem is when you start letting people
live in delusion they start to think
their delusion is reality and so that's
that's when you see like like they're
taking away titles from women yeah and
so like I'm an athlete I played
basketball for like I don't even know
anymore 15 20 years I don't even know
but like like to think that someone
could just transition and take away a
title is mad and it takes away
opportunities for real women by the way
I think it's important to note that all
of the negative Downstream repercussions
of this entire cultural psychosis only
impact women
right only impact women men are not
worried about women transitioning into
men and taking their Sports record or
being in their changing rooms or being
put in they're not concerned about
females entering male prisons and so on
the same is not the true the other way
around why because the Sexes are
different and everyone knows it you may
have I don't know if you know this do
you know that there are males who are
identifying as women getting transferred
into female prisons and suddenly female
prisoners are getting pregnant how do
you think that is happening hmm let's
put this let's put this together right
and it's women who are being put at risk
from this right it's women who are
getting their records broken by
wonderful ladies such as myself
um it's women who are losing their
college scholarships for for sports who
are having men with their penises and
testicles out in their spas in their
changing rooms so on and so forth all
the negative impacts are on women as far
as I'm concerned the people I mean it's
not affected you yet but the way things
are going it will wait until they start
taking away your rights as a woman yeah
and saying there are rights because
we're women or if you have a daughter
you know and she has to then compete and
she's sporty and has to now compete
against boys and the thing is is that I
remember growing up years ago and I
didn't know there was a
I think she was a lady and her daughter
I could have been a man so many years
ago but she though she'd had the
operation and she changed I never knew
as far as I'm concerned that was just I
think it was her dad and she was a woman
before but whatever she had
transgendered into whether it's a
daughter or a man but it wasn't like oh
yes you know I'm now a man and I need
these rights and I need those rights and
I need this no it was just she just got
on with her life she didn't ask anything
of anybody she didn't try and RAM her
sexuality or her gender down people's
throats yeah as far as I'm concerned if
that's what you want to go and do go and
do it but don't tell me who I am I don't
make it affect my life yeah and don't
try and influence children society and
everybody else with it that's how you
want to be yeah I'm the same with
everybody whether you're gay of my best
friend's gay he's gay that's his
business
but he's not going to try and rub it
down my throat or anything like that
mm-hmm yeah that's down to him you're
allowed to believe whatever you want to
believe whether some people think it's
absurd or not you're not allowed to
force other people to believe and accept
that yeah right this goes for absolutely
everything it goes Way Beyond this issue
this is our understanding of religious
beliefs political beliefs social beliefs
culturally right everyone is allowed to
believe what they want there's billions
of people in the world we don't we don't
all share the same belief systems but if
I were to come and now try to force all
the things that I believe on someone
else I can believe that this this table
is circular and yellow I have a right to
believe that I don't have a right to try
to force everyone else in this room and
everyone else in the world to to believe
and accept and say that this table is
circular and yellow when they can see
its rectangular and black right so I
have a right I have a right to believe
that I can believe I can believe
whatever I want I can believe that I'm a
goat I can believe I'm a chicken I can
walk around on all fours and eat out of
a dog bowl if I want I can do that I
have the right to do that I can't force
everyone else to someone might be super
polite and you know pet me and treat me
like a dog or a goat or whatever you
know right if they want to but I can't I
can't force people to right if someone
is like no that's that's a man walking
around pretending to be a goat that's
not a goat right and that could hurt my
feelings if I genuinely believe I'm a
goat but if if this ever happens by the
way please like get me some help
um but just using these examples but
yeah you you can believe whatever you
like but the problem with this issue and
why it's become such a contentious issue
is because it's gone far beyond people
just living their lives and doing what
they want to do it's got into an
ideological movement where they are now
trying to force people to believe and
comply with it oftentimes at the threat
of punishment someone said that why are
they not answering that question someone
said because they'll get fired right
that's coercion right if you are not
allowed to say something that is
factually correct and true because
you're worried about losing your job
you're not in a good place in society
that actually happened to me today in a
few foreign
to one of his students as they and
actually lost his job yeah and then
because he was so pronounced about it
understandably he went back to his job
his place of work the school he's worked
in for the past half many years and
tried to re-enter the school you got
arrested yeah it's a real thing in
Canada it's illegal to so-called
misgender somebody but they didn't care
about his religion over that do they
they didn't put you know the fact that
he's Catholic and he has strong beliefs
that actually came underneath someone
wanting to be called day yeah but is
that not not you're not considering that
other person's feelings I don't care
about that
their feelings don't matter their
feelings don't matter you're saying that
they shouldn't impose their beliefs on
you but refusing to call someone that
what they identity handsome
and wonderful and successful those are
my preferred adjectives
right
you will hurt my feelings if you don't
refer to me as jacked handsome
intelligent charming and so
I I don't have you have a right to
freedom of speech I don't have a right
to control your language
that's not how it works there's no
there's no right to not have your
feelings hurt there's no right to
control other people's language the
right is on the other side so yes people
should be polite and kind and civil
within reason but actually if you are
now trying to control someone else's
language and force them to call you
something especially something that you
are not you don't have a right to do
that at all at all that's not all right
if I turn around I said she
from today I'm going to be a virgin
um forget about don't worry about the
three grandchildren I'm a 36 year old
son yeah
and I'm not going and anybody else who
says to me that I'm not a virgin I'm
going to sue them I'm going to go to
newspapers and I'm going to make me up
in ours because I am now identifying as
a virgin
and I and I said to you you have to see
me as a virgin would you feel happy
about that but I think we keep creating
examples that are not very relative to
this conversation obviously being a
virgin that is a very objective thing
someone identifying as a man or woman
we've not been able to identify it we've
not been able to explain what a man and
a woman is if there was
everyone else has well you guys have
because you have one way of thinking
you've decided as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible